- I don't sound like that okay.
Do I sound like that?
- My name is Alfredo Crossman Chavez, Jr.
I've been teaching gym or five years now.
- Hi, my name is Denisha Kane
and I've been a gym teacher for 14 years.
- Do I use Tiktok?
Yes I do.
At first I did not.
I'm not going to say I was anti Tiktok.
I was just like,
I don't know how to
maneuver through this app.
- I don't generally Tiktok.
I figured after Instagram,
when Snapchat and Tiktok started,
I said, you know what?
We have to leave something to the kids,
it's too much.
- When I was a kid and I was taking gym
we used to roast.
Some of it might be really good,
some of it might be like, ooh coach.
So I'm excited.
- I'm excited to see what these kids think
and what they got to say.
Let's get cracking.
- The accuracy.
I really love this video.
- It's the arm thing for me though.
Cause us coaches like to call this
the Tyrannosaurus Rex arms.
You're gonna hear us go,
pop your arm, pop ya arms.
- There are so many
different styles of runners.
You can tell the arm flailers,
they're like the lazy kids,
don't really feel like running.
And then you have those who like
are on the track team
or just hella athletic
and they wanna outdo each other so.
- Johnny, Johnny get up.
This is why you're fat.
Come on.
- Wait what, wait wait hold on hold on.
- Wait wait.
- Why are you such a ho get up.
- Wait whoa hold on no no no no.
She called,
she said what?
- No teacher would ever ever.
There's your job.
Hi, goodbye.
Go up to an appointment.
But it's hilarious.
- I know this is a prank but like
if I was her son I
would've closed the zoom
like mom no you're bugging.
You can't, mom you can't do that.
- Whenever I was in gym
class I would tell my teacher
that my back was hurting
because it (beep) was
and I didn't wanna run the mile
and then my teacher asked me,
she was like do you have proof?
And I was like sorry did you
want me to pull out my spine
and show you where the pain was .
- Oh my god.
- There are P.E. teachers out there
who throw people into the mile.
They don't train the kids for it,
get the kids well prepared for it
so I feel for him if he's in
that particular environment.
But if he's not though,
you know what I'm saying kids be lying
about them injuries man
you gotta watch them.
- Okay first of all,
we have to ask for notes
if there's a type of medical situation.
And we know you lazy,
we know you don't wanna run.
Cause we were in gym we were lazy
and we didn't wanna run
so we know what your game plan is, sir.
Don't be calling us the b word.
- This is where you'll
come every single day
before class starts.
This is the area where
you will be changing.
Where did I say you
guys would be changing?
That we need to change in here
but I was just wondering
Exactly, you change here.
In this locker room.
If I catch a single one of you guys
changing in the bathroom stalls
everybody in this class will be running
15 extra laps.
Okay.
- Every gym teacher's
go to is always laps.
I mean bathroom stalls is
there for you to change.
Why can't we use them?
Come on now.
- I don't sound like that okay.
Do I sound like that?
But I don't mind,
honestly if a person is uncomfortable
and they wanna get
dressed in the bathroom,
I don't really have a problem with that.
I've never really known
teachers to trip off of that
cause I've never ever had
a student ask me that.
They just do what they do
and we do what we do.
All right next video.
- We're doing the pacer test today,
I want all my boys to line up
right here on this white line.
I can get down on all fours
and crawl from this end
of the gym to the other
in the time it takes
between the first lap beep.
I will show you right now.
Watch me.
- Ayo!
Shorty said I got a point to prove
and Imma prove it today yo.
I have not done that before
but I have sped walked the first lap
to show kids about pace
but lowkey the pacer was
kinda like cool for me.
Pacer was like the fun test,
like you start off slow build up fast.
You saw it as being
competition with your friends
like I never had a problem
with the pacer right.
- This is definitely something
that happens in gym class.
We have to demonstrate what it is
the you know activity is
supposed to look like,
or to be sure that you can do it properly.
She be clowning us.
But I have,
I have done that,
I've experienced that in teaching.
These Tiktoks were so much fun
they were really funny.
It does encourage me to
watch more Tiktok videos
because they're fun.
Maybe I'll go and download the app
and just be a looky loo
probably won't be posting very much
but I'll get my look on see
what you guys got going on.
These are fun, these are funny.
- My overall thoughts is they were funny,
they were hilarious honestly.
Very relatable especially
to my past experiences
as a kid growing up.
Love the laughter,
love the creativity by the students.
Get your laps!
Three laps!
I'm just kidding I don't do that.